I'm the head
instructor for 15.662,
How to Secure the American
Dream for the Next Generation
Workforce.
I'd like to take a
little time to tell
you a little bit
about myself and why
I'm offering this course.
I've been studying,
and teaching,
and working on issues
about the nature
of work for the last 40 years.
I've never been more concerned
about the future of work
than I am right now.
I'm concerned about the need
for more jobs, better jobs,
for you and for all people
in the next generation.
And so I think we can work
together in this course
to explore how you can
address these issues
and secure your future as well.
So let me tell you a little
bit about my background
so you can understand
where I'm coming from.
I grew up on a small
family farm in Wisconsin.
We learned at a very
early age the importance
of working together,
the value of hard work,
and the satisfaction that comes
from doing a job very well.
My father only had an
eighth grade education,
but he told all of us, my
brother and my sisters,
get as much education
as you can so that you
can get an occupation and a
career that is better than what
farming will be in the future.
That was clearly the best
advice I could have ever gotten,
and it worked.
Here I am, many years
later, an MIT professor,
thanks to a good education
from the schools in Wisconsin
and from the University
of Wisconsin.
So in my professional
life I've been
fortunate to work with a
wide variety of business,
and labor, and government
organizations over the years,
and I've been a
constant advocate
for improving relations
at the workplace,
for getting people
to work together,
to think about how the
workforce is changing,
and how they need
to change to meet
the conditions of the
economy, and the society,
and the workforce that
we find ourselves in.
And so that's what I want
to do in this course:
to engage you, the next
generation workers, and those
of us in the baby boom
generation who still care
about these issues
and want to make
a contribution to
a discussion of how
we can improve the workplace.
And I want to especially
learn and listen from you.
I'm engaged in writing
a book on this topic,
and I want to get your
ideas so you help shape
how we're going to change,
how we're going to adapt,
and how we're going to create
the workplace of the future.
I'm Barbara Dyer, president and
CEO of the Hitachi Foundation
and senior lecturer at MIT
Sloan School of Management.
The Hitachi Foundation
focuses on the role
of business in society,
with a particular emphasis
on how businesses create
social and economic value
in the pursuit of profits.
We'll be talking about start up
companies and their motivation
to create a real
benefit for society,
and we'll be talking some
about traditional businesses,
more long term businesses, and
the ways in which they create
social value and
environmental value,
and the lessons that can be
learned across the spectrum,
from early stage businesses
to later stage businesses.
I'm Zeynep Ton.
I'm an adjunct
associate professor
at MIT Sloan in the
Operations Management group.
I will tell you about how
we can create companies
that deliver great value
to their investors,
good jobs for their
employees, and great value
to their customers
all at the same time.
I'm Christine Riordan, a Ph.D.
Student at MIT's Institute
for Work and
Employment Research.
I am going to be talking to
you about how labor unions are
reinventing themselves, and how
new forms of worker advocacy
can help support your
aspirations for work.
I'm Francesca Cicileo,
an undergraduate at MIT.
I'm going to tell
you more about what
our generation, the
so-called millennials,
say are their goals and
aspirations for work,
and their version of
the American dream.
Hello, my name's John McCarthy.
I'm a postdoctoral fellow here
at MIT's Institute for Work
and Employment Research.
I'm going to be talking
to you about freelancing
work, including new
technology-mediated work
arrangements that are springing
up across the economy.
We're going to look at some
of the positive and negative
aspects of these
work arrangements,
and also talk about how work
institutions might emerge
to ameliorate some of the
negative aspects of these work
arrangements.
So I hope we will learn
together, and then
let's take our lessons and
our message to the broader
audiences, to future
leaders, in this country
and around the world.